[Music]
Dora stay for dinner if you think you
know door she'll grow out of it
think again hey Dora this isn't the
jungle it's high school
it's life or death so if I don't talk to
you don't take a person oh okay we're
all just trying to survive high schools
a horrible nightmare are you I'm glad
you brought it I'm just kidding I don't
actually care we're on to something big
Dora an ancient city made of gold we're
gonna break some rules we're coming with
you Prima oh look Dora brought a knife
on the field trip everybody
[Music]
it's a jungle puzzle
the jungle is perfectly safe
[Music]
seriously you had that in your backpack
too
don't panic excuse me hey chili con
carne honey here's your satellite phone
call us any time and you can track our
coordinates on your manner but it's not
the same I'm an explorer like you know
honey you have the whole world to
explore go see it make friends that's
real exploring
I don't know how yes you're to just be
yourself door okay
come on you're gonna miss your flight
Dora no monkeys in the city
[Music]
she knows buddy
[Music]
take a seat young lady what's happening
come on we're gonna have a talk about
the dangers of the big city see you're
gonna be invited to some parties and
some of these parties they're called
raves the people that are called Reavers
yeah and then they love glow sticks and
and candy necklaces and hacky sacks the
music is it sounds like this okay well
be careful that that's what we want to
say are you sure you should be touching
it not sound like a good noise
it's an ancient underground aqueducts
Inka engineers with some of the most
elaborate irrigation systems ever
devised water from above using crappy
[Music]
the curse is gonna purchase we're gonna
perish all over the place Oh [ __ ] now
follow me
[Music]
oh no it was just
I think we're safe all those that seek
better but there shall surely perish
okay I am ready for my parents to come
and get me now you have nothing to worry
about I promise I mean there's no need
to over react and that was just an
example of the dangers of overreacting
you know the jungle it's a part of you
but exploring is not a game and you
don't look before you leave
okay but we're onto something big Dora
an ancient city made of gold but about
that and your mother and I are gonna
prove it
Amy I'm sorry sweetie you're not going
look being in the city around kids your
own age like Diego might help are you
gonna get invited some of these parties
called rapes the music sounds like this
got it be careful that's what we want to
say cousin Diego you're so skinny and
tough you are way more energetic than I
remember Dora this isn't the jungle it's
high school it's life or death keep a
low profile yes
and just be cool door okay what is this
where did you transfer from the jungle
here's the scavenger hunt list team out
in groups of four hola Dora
you'll help us find your parents and the
lost city of gold where are we
all I see is jungle see three
mercenaries armed oh look Dora on a
knife on the field trip everybody maybe
you want to leave we're with your
parents you're all in danger we're gonna
die out here there's no need to
overreact of course she knows this
monkey
[Applause]
[Music]
I have to keep going no matter what
she's freaking awesome I think we're
safe
[Music]